I'm not saying let's live forever I
don't think any transhumanists are
saying that I think what we want is the
choice to be able to live indefinitely
that might be 10,000 years and might
only be 170 years
hi I'm Zack Weiss Muller for Reason TV
we're here with Zoltan Istvan he is a
philosopher futurist and writer of the
book the transhumanist wager he's also
announced his intentions to run for
president with the transhumanist party
Zoltan thank you very much for talking
to us thanks for having me
what is transhumanism is it a political
ideology is it social movement explain
what it is well it's really all the
above but I like to just refer to it as
kind of an international movement of
people that are trying to use science
and technology to radically enhance the
human being and also enhance the human
experience but it's really about using
science and technology to improve the
species itself what are some examples of
how you would do that one of my favorite
examples is heart disease they have been
testing out robotic hearts in France and
you know hard to see some number one
killer in America at some point in the
future hopefully within ten years we
will electively start having heart
transplants with these robotic hearts
and this is a classic transhumance
technology that could literally
eliminate heart disease just to get a
little background on you you were a
National Geographic reporter or a kind
of world traveler how did those
experiences bring you to transhumanism
one of the stories I was doing was on in
Vietnam on bomb diggers but we dropped
you know millions of tons of bombs on
Vietnam about 10 or 15% of those bombs
went unexploded and I was doing a story
on the locals that are digging up these
unexploded bombs and selling the metal
for money I came very close to stepping
on a landmine my guy pushed me out of
the way on while I was on assignment in
the Demilitarized Zone there in Vietnam
and after four years of doing some
really heavy reporting including
covering the Kashmir war I just kind of
thought I was sort of done with
dangerous things and I want to actually
contribute something that in case
something bad did happen I could
actually you know help that that
movement forward and transhumanism is
really I say the number one goal
transhumanism is trying to conquer
death so that is the stated goal of
transhumanism is to actually overcome
death well that's certainly I would say
the top priority of most transhumanist
but the goals of transhumanists are
pretty varied - I'd say a lot of them
want to also improve their life some
want to completely eliminate suffering
others just want to have it so that they
could have kind of new body parts so
they can do incredible things new sports
you know run as fast as Cheetahs I mean
these are all things that are part of
the transhumans future so there's a lot
of reasons for doing it but I'd say the
number one reason is transhumanists
would like to overcome human death
people get suspicious and maybe even a
little creeped out when you are trying
to take death out of the equation
because then you're starting to become
something that is not quite human and
it's unsettling for some people how do
we get people to overcome that kind of
innate revulsion and keep pushing
forward when they first hear about these
things to begin with the very best way
to do that is to try to change the kind
of the paradigm that we sort of all
believe in America and many places
around the world are quite religious
especially America I was just writing an
article the poll said 83% still are
declaring themselves selves Christian
and that makes it hard to want to take
death out of the equation because a
natural part of the Christian ideology
is to die and to eventually reach an
afterlife with God and transhumanist
it's not that they're anti religious or
they're only atheist because they're not
there all across the board but
overcoming death is not something that's
associated in a kind of a religious
framework they simply associate it with
wanting to just live indefinitely
because they love life and so I'm trying
to as a transhumanist tell people the
same thing it's it's not that wanting to
live indefinitely is something that is
going to intrude or conflict with one's
religion it's just something that is the
kind of evolving nature of the species
and if you can get people to think like
that and not see it in conflict with
their ideologies then I think they're
gonna be more on board with saying yeah
it's good to live 150 200 years and
again I'm not saying let's live forever
I don't think any transhumanists are
saying that I think what we want is the
choice to be able to live indefinitely
that
might be 10,000 years that might only be
170 years and do you think most people
want to live for thousands or tens of
thousands of years
absolutely I'm convinced that what has
happened is we have been taught that we
should die we have been taught the the
this taboo of living indefinitely or
having too much power because after all
except for the last few hundred years
we've been a species that's been subject
to diseases and war and and lots of
terrible things
once people think it through and once
people realize that this science and
technology is actually here and
certainly will be here I think in 10 20
30 years when they start stopping aging
and reversing aging they're gonna start
saying wow this this is great yeah I can
have multiple careers I can have more
time my family I can watch my kids you
know grow to whatever they want to do we
talked a little bit about the kind of
sense of disgust or revulsion people
just innately feel when when they think
of something that's in between human and
and non-human and there's another group
of people that face that in a very real
way by defying categories and that would
be people in the transgender movement
and you wrote a very interesting article
for Psychology Today about the overlap
between the LGBT movement and the
transhumanism could you explain that a
little bit why do you see a common
ground there the LGBT movement and
transhumanist transhumanism has kind of
a common bond in fighting for basic
civil rights to do what they want with
their bodies we generally call this
morphological freedom and this idea - we
have the right to do with you know
ourselves whatever we want as long as
it's not hurting someone and so I
believe that we should try to merge the
movements a little bit more and use each
other as a way to open up the the
dialogue because the LGBT movement is
also going to be changing because of
transhumanism we're moving to a world
where there's going to be post gender
ISM you know there might not be gender
there's going to be this ecto Genesis
concept or artificial wombs they're
gonna have designer babies that might
not even have a uterus in them because
some women don't want to have menstrual
cycles we're getting to a world where
science and technology could be
drastically changing the human being
such that the LGBT movement will have to
transform itself and frankly it's going
to become
it's gonna merge in a way with
transhumanism what does the government's
role and politicians role need to be in
this you know I tend to think that it's
best when government sort of stays out
of the way but I think one of the main
things that we're pushing for is for
example where we're involved in all
these far-off Wars all over the place
America is I would have suggested that
we take a significant portion of the
defense budget and I don't mean a giant
portion but just a portion of it instead
of spending it on far-off horse we spend
it on life extension medicine this is
something that we can directly do for
the people we can improve their health
if we spent 1 trillion dollars in the
life extension industry I'd say within
10 years we would literally conquer
human mortality from my perspective it
seems like the government gets in the
way of a lot of the innovations that
you're talking about when we see things
like 23andme which is a technology that
allows you to look at your own genome
FDA put the kibosh on it genetically
modified organisms there's this ongoing
fear and legislation surrounding that
there's anxiety about genetic
engineering of babies will the state
stop transhumanism and its tracks or are
you optimistic that it can overcome and
route around that obstacle I absolutely
believe that the government creates way
too much red tape and and way too much
bureaucracy and slows down the process
for example when George Bush stopped for
stem-cell development for 8 years you
know we lost ground in that technology
and that technology is now promising to
be one of the most important
technologies of the 21st century I think
they get in the way and they shouldn't
be allowed to get in the way I have
actually advocated for some type of
policy that would say it's actually
illegal for government to get in the way
when it concerns life extension
medicines and technologies looking
forward to let's say the next five to
ten years one of the most promising
technologies in achieving life extension
3d printing of organs basically most
people die from organ failure and if you
could create new types of organs either
by 3d printing them with some type of
material or by creating robotic organs
or just by improving the organs that we
have you can piece by piece make it
so that whenever you get a prom you're
able to fix it and therefore this you
know the human being can live longer I
think one of the other really important
technologies that came out this last
year that's been in the news is this
suspended animation where they're taking
gunshot victims in the university in
Pittsburgh and they're able to keep them
clinically dead for two to four hours
just because they put saline through
their system and they keep them very
cool and then they're able to bring them
back after they've kind of fixed them
all up next year it might be eight hours
in five years it could easily be 24
hours
a scientist specifically are starting to
fuzz the line between life and death and
the more resources we spend on this as a
nation the more we encourage engine you
know innovation regarding these things
then we're gonna find ourselves living
longer and better and just you know
feeling our well-being and our safety is
much more intact than it's ever been
Zoltan Istvan thank you very much for
talking to us thanks so much for having
me for reason TV I'm Zack Weissmuller